the future of the smartphone has been on
display in Barcelona Spain this week MWC
Barcelona formerly known as the Mobile
World Congress is the biggest smartphone
event on the planet and this year it's
been dominated by one emerging
technology the incredibly fast 5g
networks that will usher in a new
generation of communications here to
tell us what we can expect and about
some controversial aspects of 5g is seen
that editor-at-large and CBS News
contributor Dan Ackerman dan thanks for
joining us first right off the bat the
basics on this what can consumers expect
from 5g the promise of 5g which they've
been selling very hard for the last
couple of years is that your phone
connection will be faster than your
broadband at home connection and in fact
that will become the primary way we
connect at home through our phones to
other devices but also things like
self-driving cars and all sorts of smart
Internet of Things devices will all be
on the superfast shared network what is
right I wouldn't say what about the cost
that's what people always seem to want
to know sure and you know what every
time there's a there's a new generation
of phones or phone service you're never
really in the long run to end up paying
less that's not the business models oh
yeah hardware companies and the data
providers we want it faster just don't
want to pay more for it and besides just
buying a fancy new phone which you'll
need to do and getting a new service
plan which may not cost more at first
but eventually they'll get up there
you'll be paying for 5g service at home
if you want that and who's gonna pay for
the connection to your car to your
washing machine these are all things we
have to figure out is this really gonna
be as transformative as as advertised in
well when you link back to about 2010
when we started to move to 4G from the
3G and older networks it really did make
a huge difference and right now you
can't have things that need to be online
or you know rock-solid all the time like
self-driving cars on regular 4G phone
networks it's just not stable enough so
this will give us a chance to feel like
everything is always on rock-solid
stable so is our infrastructure ready
for all of this it's a slow rollout some
companies like AT&T and Verizon are
already talking about starting small
pockets of service but that's really
just a beginning you have to build out a
lot of areas there's still parts of the
country where you can't get good four
G's
servus well you can't get quad-band
internet service at home so there's
gonna be a really big crossover piece
but how long do you think it's gonna
take then you know it comes down to the
the hardware manufacturers and the
service providers the service providers
eighteen team Verizon they need to get
these little micro cells up all over the
place that will take a long time some
areas may never have it and for the
hardware manufacturers the first 5g
phones just getting announced last week
week before don't really have a street
date form sometime this year they said
there's only five in the world well I
tried to get one of Samsung's new ones
there's only a handful of prototypes of
that right so that's not ready yet even
though it should be on sale maybe in the
second quarter of second half of this
year but the you know Apple they're not
gonna have this until 2020 at least and
that's when you know it's starting to go
mainstream when the latest iPhone has
then the fe infrastructure is not ready
you don't want it until nighttime right
if you live in a big city you'll
probably be first or one of their select
markets where they started out it's
gonna be a few years but we may look
back and say I don't remember what I was
doing when I dropped a call or couldn't
get online somewhere that was crazy
that's always something new like I got
to go buy a new phone again all of a
sudden Dan thank you for that good news
I guess we're good news for absolutely